what are your feelings on the mail in
voting well i'm gonna make two very
bold predictions number one
i know in pennsylvania for example
you're exactly right that you have
two envelopes you gotta put your ballot
in you got the first one and the second
one
and if it's not in both of them it's not
counted and i believe that is going to
actually
hurt the democrats the majority of
conservatives are going to be voting
in person majority of democrats voting
by mail
i think we're going to see and i don't
want this because i don't want voters to
be disenfranchised i want them to be
heard
but we're gonna see tens of thousands
if not i believe california had a
hundred thousand ballots that they threw
out
that they didn't count we're going to
see a very
high number of ballots that are not
counted and i think the majority of them
are going to be democrat
also listen to this you got all these
kids that are not in school because of
covet right
florida state penn state ohio state
so let's talk about center county where
uh penn state is for a second
historically blue a lot of those kids
are back home they're in jersey they're
in
new york they're in illinois you think
that they're gonna be
turning in an absentee ballot to vote in
pennsylvania i don't think so because i
remember as a college student i was
pretty losing myself so
i think we're going to see historically
blue counties where all these college
students vote
i think we're going to see tens of
thousands fewer
voters for the democrat party because of
kovitz i have another theory what's up
you guys remember when donald trump did
that uh that rally was it tulsa i think
uh-huh and it was like it was a fizzle i
suppose like they were expecting we have
a million registrations
everyone's come with this big outdoor
area and then it was like six to seven
thousand people
that's what the democrats are doing
right now so when you put on the nfl
black lives matter mlb black lives
matter nba black lives matter every
single show amazon boom you turn on call
of duty and like a thing pops up and
it's like do you support black lives
matter i don't know if it was call of
duty but apparently like some video
games were doing this
here's what's going to happen the
pollsters are going to call and there's
going to be some dude sitting in his you
know lounge chair with like a bowl of
barbecue chips on his stomach as he's
watching you know
he's watching ozark or something and
then he eats his phone call and it rings
and he's like
calling me hello and they're like hi i'm
a pollster and i want to ask you
questions
okay who are you voting for uh i don't
know a
abide in i guess do you support black
lives matter oh yeah yeah
you're for sure whatever okay yeah
thanks bonnie hangs up and then goes
back to stuffing his face with barbecue
chips
when people are being slapped in the
face over and over again politics
politics biden black lives matter go
voting
they're going to be sitting there and
they're going to just play along they're
going to be like yeah yeah oh yeah i'm
doing that
that thing for sure and then vote the
election day's gonna come
and he's gonna be sitting in his chair
with the barbecue chips on his chest you
know and he's on his belly and he's
gonna be eating it
and then he's gonna look at his phone
it's gonna go election day and he goes
and he's gonna look at the tv and then
he's looked down at the chips and he's
gonna put his phone back keeping the
chips
they're not gonna go out i think they're
tricking themselves in
and what i think hap so i was reading
about what happened with trump's rally
apparently the email to rsvp said rsvp
anyway to show your support for trump
so then a bunch of people who never plan
plan on going signed up giving him a
million
rsvps only 6 7 000 people actually want
to show up in person a lot of people did
watch online it was pretty big
so this is what i think the democrats
are doing if you in if you
do this massive influx of black lives
matter and democrat politics in
pop culture then you're gonna get a
bunch of young people being like yeah
donald trump's so
dumb like dude we're gonna go so we're
so gonna go vote they're not gonna vote
dude
they're gonna be sitting there smoking
pot and like making tick-tock videos and
they're gonna be like
yo did you guys vote no did you nah
you guys want to order papa john's yeah
all right
that's that's it i actually cheated and
had papa john's earlier
i won't but i will never turn down more
pizza
i won't do papa john's anymore man we
with john schneider
oh i thought you were being for real i
was like uh gosh after he's saying about
barbecue chips i'm hungry
no i won't eat papa john's oh okay no
for real yeah because uh
you know what happened with papa john
right
he was on a phone call and he was
complaining
that like colonel sanders used the
n-word and the media never like
you know he it was like it was no big
deal but he said the n-word
so then someone leaked the audio and
they claimed that like an
employee for a company a third party
that was listening was offended at his
use of the word
it's like what he literally just said
the word he was using it in a context
where the word was bad
and he was angry that someone wasn't
being held accountable like it wasn't
fair and then they stripped his name off
like his the
university where he made donations yeah
he got ousted from the company his
company
his company and they've like they just
bludgeoned him over the head
over yeah for and i think it was just
you know hostile takeover was someone's
opportunity to make money like ah we got
him now
there was a guy at netflix this is my
favorite story and he was going over a
list of offensive words with the staff
and he said the n word so they went to
hr and they complained
so hr calls him in and like what
happened and he explained like i was
just going through the list of offensive
words that don't appear on netflix
and what are the words well you've got
this word that word and word and they
went
he said it again so they fired him yeah
i think
netflix is getting hit with a lawsuit
right now oh they got indicted
netflix you see do you hear about this
netflix got indicted by texas
for the cuties film oh good yep good
this is crazy stuff on what was the
charge uh
i guess i don't know the exact charge
but they said it was for
prurient uh sexual conduct or something
wow
yeah basically it was a state a state
hit him with it right
uh it was a county it's texas county so
so basically uh the cuties film for
those who don't know is about
11 year old girls doing adult dances
you know fully clothed or whatever but
there's some really gross stuff in the
movie
and there's a few scenes that are
overtly sexual acts
innate like it's over like so uh
i don't even want to explain what the
girls do but let me just say there's a
scene where the girls do an overt sex
acts
it's like it's hard to describe because
it's not like
it's it's not porn it's what they
described as like
fully clothed girls engaging in a sexual
activity of some sort so that was part
of the indictment where they're like
that scene is clearly gratuitous
children
like a treatise it is children doing
overt behaviors
fully you know clothed or otherwise
partially clothed or fully clothed
and that was illegal and so they're
being indicted for it so if you are
curious period means having or
encouraging an excessive interest in
sexual matters
wow i would say that is can you spell
that please p r u
r i e n t m learn something new
well i think there comes you know it's
such a difficult balance because we are
freedom fighters
and you know we believe in being free
speech absolutists etc
so i would have at least like to see
first
something sent out to netflix saying
look
this is overtly sexual you have this
many days to take this down otherwise we
are going to take litigious action
against you that did happen
say it again like i think it was like
that did happen okay god 33 republicans
several attorneys pelosi's daughter
nancy pelosi's daughter and they still
didn't take it down after they defended
it
yep and and this this movie has like
that's that's crazy i can't believe they
didn't even like the the ads for the
movie were
like the clips on youtube the trailer it
was just too much
they argue but the movie is opposing
these behaviors it's like so you took
little girls you trained them to do
these things you filmed them doing it
to claim it's bad like yeah i'm not
buying it dude i'm not buying it so well
and if
you've ever seen the movie 13 it's about
these girls this good girl meets this
bad girl and it kind of shows how she
goes down this terrible roller coaster
and it does include not anything overtly
sexual but you know that you know
they're going through that age and drugs
and alcohol
and i think the difference is cuties was
more
glorifying at least it looked like it
was glorifying from the ads whereas the
movie 13
it was painting a very dark picture
about how this good girl
her life completely went downhill when
she started doing all these different
acts
and i think uh there's a difference if
you're trying to make that message
don't glorify the sexuality they don't
need to even show it
they could imply it yeah implied
absolutely so you know
the way i explained it is there's a
three-minute dance scene at the end
which is one like the most gratuitous
where
that's where the overt act takes place i
don't describe what it is man i think
this is disgusting
but all they had to do was show the
girls like
watching that they didn't have to have
the girls watch any videos
you could have a hands holding a phone
watching an adult dance
of some sort then you can have a scene
change where it shows the girl looking
at
all the girls looking at the phone from
the other side so the actual
young actresses aren't watching the
video then when you have them actually
go on the stage to perform the dance you
have an idea of what the dance already
is
and you don't actually have little girls
doing it you just show reactions from
the audience
gasping and like looking shocked and
getting offended and angry
and then it ends the little girls
realizing like everyone's mad at us
because that's apparently what happens
in the film instead for three minutes
they're like
showing these girls doing all this stuff
and it's messed up
so my my my point for this whole film
has been like
if you were really trying to say it was
bad you don't need three
minutes to show it it could have even
like if their argument was no we have to
okay five seconds
ten seconds why three minutes nah they
just wanted it it was a
french film oh yeah it seems like we're
in the age of like sexual liberation
in a way with like you know the lgbtq
movement and like the you know the new
genders and things like that
but this is showing that pedophilia is a
step
too far is what it feels it's not it's
abusing children it's not the same thing
as having
an orient having an orientation they're
oh not at all they're
but this is also like a sexually
liberative movement of showing children
in sexual
positions and period behavior and i
think that's just what they're what
we're seeing is in the united states
it's too far
i disagree i think it's exploitation it
is a form of exploitation
it's not liberation in any sense well i
think the french filmmaker thought of it
like that
no her excuse was that it was
criticizing all of it saying it was bad
not liberating she said it was bad and
the movie ends with the girl realizing
it was an awful thing to do
that's like saying let me show you how
bad it is when i punch you and then
punching you in the face see how bad
this is it's like you can't that doesn't
no the way i put it is like imagine if
we were like we're gonna make a movie
about how drugs are bad for kids and
it's you know
we're gonna have a five-minute scene
where we literally give the kids crack
and we're gonna actually make the the
actors the ten-year-old actors do crack
on
that's crazy you wouldn't you would you
wouldn't have them actually do it
no that's what they did how do we end up
talking about this
oh we're talking about netflix yeah yeah
yeah yeah we're talking about pills and
stuff
well since we're talking about big
corporate america for a second
oh i mentioned the netflix guy in uh
getting fired for the n-word stuff well
let's talk about the dichotomy how
leftists are always talking about
big corporate america and how they you
know
dislike walmart and amazon
and all that stuff and they want to
support small businesses yet with
covid we've seen that these big
businesses are rewarded
while all the ma and paz are shut down
well there the left has been criticizing
that but they've been criticizing it
wrong
so they're saying things like it is
wrong that amazon profited
x billion dollars and jeff bezos made
all this money sorry let me stop right
there you're half right
i i think it is wrong that these big box
stores
were given carte blanche by the local
governments and the mom and pops were
all shut down however
when when they talk about the money made
by the billionaires because like bernie
sanders is playing this game
they're talking about stock value
because of the lockdowns
so if you own stock in amazon there's no
stores
so stock value for amazon went up
because they're like well everyone's
going to be buying through amazon now
because you can't go anywhere else
so your stock value goes up so all these
billionaires ended up seeing their net
worth increase but they didn't actually
get
cash for it but bernie in the left uses
use that as an excuse to say we need a
wealth tax
charge them cash for the value of
something that we've assigned
it makes no sense the wealth tax this is
the most ridiculous absurd garbage
like i could give you uh there's a nine
volt battery there i can hand it to you
and say
i hereby deem that nine volt battery
worth one billion dollars
now according to the wealth tax you've
got to pay you know one percent or
something
you're like i don't have any money you
just handed me a battery yeah so it's
like someone gives you a painting
now your wealth is this high you owe a
tax on it otherwise what they seize it
or something
that whole thing doesn't make sense but
anyway yeah i i do think it's it's
messed up
mostly these democrat governors did this
and then you see what happened in
michigan
where the supreme court of michigan
ruled the lockdown was unconstitutional
yeah and gretchen whitmer said i don't
care i'm going to enforce them anyway
and she's like their ruling won't take
effect for 21 days and then after that
we're going to find alternative means
for maintaining the lockdown
wow you when you have an ex and when
people were challenging her authority
there was like petitions going around
for like a recalling her power
she said don't take my powers from me i
need that like anybody to share
something like that yeah she said don't
take the powers from me i need it to
keep us safe
and that's that you know what i would do
like if i if i had like
the power if anyone ever came to me and
said no
i must have the power i'm the okay
you're gone that that we're taking that
from you right now
you know we want leaders who are like i
do not want this power i accept it
reluctantly and i will return it
as soon as the crisis has ended well or
just the fact that she's saying
i need it to protect you she's basically
saying that she is the authority
over you and that you don't know best
how to take care of yourself and your
family she knows best
that sounds like the democrats it's
driving me crazy how just the power
structure that one governor
can decide for all of us how when we get
to go outside
or i mean not quite that extreme at this
point in the united states
um there were sacrifice the young for
the yeah where we can go what we have to
wear when we go there it's crazy that
one person has that kind of say
it's it's not right it should be bottom
up
it's supposed to be the problem is that
we have emergency powers for a reason
it's you know it's a pandemic and we're
worried about people dying
at the time when all this was starting
it made sense 15 days of slow the spread
i mean there were videos out of china
where people were just like falling over
in the street
people thought we were it was like sean
you have to see shot of the dead so like
in the beginning he's on the bus and
then he sees like someone fall over
like it was like whoa man these people
are just like watching people collapse
in the street we better take this
seriously
15 days to slow the spread are we on now
like 270 or something i don't even know
can we strip their power that's what
that's what they're trying to do
vote them out yeah this november the
next person that comes in is still going
to have access to that power so you just
you just sue the the government abolish
government
well or strip it or alter it drastically
well yeah we temporarily maybe i mean i
don't think she's supposed to be able to
do these things anyway one of the
problems we have is that over time
people find loopholes
they argue oh but the language means
this and then you end up with weird
broken systems
you know and that's where we're at right
now with that with a lot of things
didn't thomas jefferson say thomas
jefferson say something about purging
government every couple hundred years or
something like that
because like it grows good i mean all i
know is look
this is the consent of the governed
right we're consenting
to everything that's being thrown our
way i mean people are going along with
it when are people gonna finally
rebel i mean it's gonna have to come
from the people like
iran where the women are taking off
their head scarfs and they're putting
them on sticks and they're rebelling
against the ayatollah
it needs to come from the people there's
two big problems anti-fuzz rebelling
black lives matter is rebelling they're
they're they're fighting for what they
believe in conservatives aren't
the other problem is what have we seen
consistently i mean the mccloskeys just
did a press conference earlier they got
charged with felonies
i believe was a felony charge i'm not
sure how many because
people were breaking onto private
property and they pulled out their guns
felony charges the people who broke out
of the property
charges dropped so you have police who
know the conservatives will comply if
someone says arrest them it's easy
no problem dealing with a mob ooh that's
that's rough so with that guy in
milwaukee
they they were outside of his house for
hours screaming and shining lights in
his window
that a mob of people in this area had
previously set fire multiple times to
someone's home
nearly destroying it so here's the guy
in his house and he sees this
so he shows off his gun and he shows a
shotgun and he like points out the
window
the cops immediately ran in and arrested
him you know why because it's easier to
arrest the guy in his own home than it
is to deal with the mob
well and nobody was supporting him look
we could learn a lot from the democrats
uh an organized minority is louder than
a silent majority
they win the culture war because they're
outspoken
and we're going to continue as
conservatives to lose
over and over until we finally come out
like the democrats
and i'm not saying antifa i'm saying
like the democrats it's not even
conservatives though
i'm not conservative moderate
left-leaning for the most part oh yeah
liberal
it's it's i i can't i can't imagine what
i don't tru
what i don't really don't get about the
progressives notably like the intercept
anti-war progressives is that they hate
trump so much
everything they seem to have fought for
over the past decade opposing the middle
eastern wars
they don't care about no they don't care
that's the weirdest thing to me it's
like
uh you've been writing about how war is
bad for a decade
don't you think you should take the win
with trump instead of supporting joe
biden who's going to be
like really bad and make more war they
don't they
they don't care or look at bernie
sanders bernie sanders was against the
trans-pacific partnership
which on day three of becoming president
president trump signed an order stopping
tpp by the way day
three that was huge and uh he also said
he would renegotiate nafta which he did
giving us the united states mexico
canada agreement so these are policies
ending endless wars
and better trade deals that the bernie
sanders crowd would agree with
and that is simply going over the heads
not everybody
it i was the bernie sanders crowd and i
was so against the tpp i mean it's just
terrifying and then
trump stomped on it that's the reason
i'm well that's the reason i'm voting
that's the main reason that i'm voting
for him wow
or that yeah people don't realize how
crazy tpp was
i remember during occupy people were
freaking out about it so when bernie
came
and started rising this is what i really
don't understand bernie had this massive
surge of grassroots support
but a lot of his policies were similar
to trump's go back and look at the news
from the 2015-16 cycle
and there are a ton of stories where
it's like where bernie sanders and
donald trump overlap
because bernie was like
pro-working-class anti-illegal
immigration
anti-free trade he absolutely was yes he
was go back and look
he said open borders is a koch brothers
proposal
one in 2015 on a vox.com interview
and he said that illegal immigration is
hurting the working class
he did he did uh an event and i think it
was in 2018 where he said
someone asked him should we allow more
refugees to come in this country and he
said heavens
no we can't allow all these poor people
to come in there's there would be too
many people
and then what happened with bernie was
he became a millionaire
all of a sudden now oh three ounces four
i think isn't it four
oh wow maybe it's thrown up guys so you
know he stopped saying millionaire right
oh no no no i love that i
love it he used to say no no i'm serious
he used to say the millionaires and
billionaires now since he became a
billionaire i mean millionaire it's just
billionaires yeah it's great
i eat it up every day listen
you can look and there were very
specific policies that bernie and trump
support at the same time
yeah one of which was bernie um bernie
was asked
uh during the primaries i think it's
2015 or so maybe it was 2016.
he was asked about gun control and he
said it's an urban versus rural issue
he was right people who live in big
cities they've got police a minute away
they don't understand why there should
be guns everywhere
because when you have too many people
around they're like oh there's gun
violence it's a problem
in rural areas there's no cops so you
need to be able to protect yourself
there's no one you can call so you have
these two different world views bernie
pointed out i said wow that's really
cool
yeah but man he sold out the moment
the moment the dnc whatever this was he
immediately was like i remember when he
was on stage and he said if you're what
you don't like to be poor
and i was like oh there it is he's gone
i should have figured
i couldn't believe he said it i was like
wow but i'll tell you what man
i was in anaheim and there was a i think
it was a trump rally
and there were three dudes outside that
were trump supporters an old guy and two
younger guys
and there were a bunch of crazy
anti-trump people who were screaming
i talked to these three guys and i said
why are you supporting trump
and these three guys actually said
actually we were for bernie
until hillary stole it and the reason
was they felt bernie actually cared
about the unions and the working class
and was going to help them out they
thought trump was okay because he talked
about similar things but trump wasn't a
politician so they felt bernie would
know how to navigate the system better
hillary clinton then stole it so their
only choice was donald trump
and donald trump got rid of the tpp
which was freaking a lot of these people
out
what people don't realize man is how
scary the tpp was for like a middle-aged
white working class guy in the middle of
the country
because what they were saying was
remember how you used to have a factory
here and then it got like
shut down and they moved to other
countries were
uh hillary clinton barack obama joe
biden were promising to do that
tenfold at the tpp they were gonna send
a whole bunch more factories in our jobs
to china so you had these people in
these small towns that were like
my life has been destroyed by this by
these free trade agreements and you had
bernie and trump saying tpp is bad
then bernie goes out and sells out to
the democrats and they're like gotta
vote for trump day three
you said trump gets rid of the tpp i
remember this
a video of this like middle-aged white
dude crying
saying that trump saved his his his town
that his factory was staying
he was making money again he got his job
back now he was saving again he was
worried that his kids were going to go
homeless and donald trump saved his life
that's what they completely ignore that
when you look at what barack obama was
doing
it was a slow erosion of our our jobs
now i love this cnn fact check
this guy is like under donald trump
we've lost
you know 157 000 jobs
not telling everyone it's actually kovid
and we actually
gained like hundreds of thousands or
millions of jobs under trump until covet
hit
and then the governors shut the jobs
down they blame they blame trump for
this
so thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you